[Music]
hi I'm Christopher Hine and we're up
here in lower Yosemite so this is Lewis
Creek in California it's a really
beautiful spot and so we're up here
you're gonna talk a little bit about
mental training in Aikido and and what
the mental training is about and I think
a lot of people get into Aikido because
of the mental aspects of training and
that might be more important to a lot of
Aikido students than the physical
aspects and definitely Aikido is a
martial art that that walks that line a
lot in between the physical and the
non-physical in fact the word Ikey could
be translated as non-physical harmony
right so key is a word the Japanese used
to mean something that's kind of an
abstract energy it's hard to get a
handle on so like things like mood or
feeling or intent those are kinds of key
like they're energy that's hard to track
down exactly what it is the the kanji
for key is rice and steam coming off of
the ricer some kind of gas vapor coming
off the rice and I think that's a nice
explanation of what key means because
it's this this kind of thing that's hard
to get a hold of and you think of steam
coming off of something it's it's like
well you can't put steam in a jar and
take it with you and use it later and
you can't grab steam in your hand but at
the same time steam can burn the hell
out of you and steam can power a
locomotive and it can do all kinds of
stuff so steam is really powerful but
it's kind of weird it's kind of abstract
it's hard to get a handle on exactly
what it is
and so he is this kind of energy that's
hard enough to handle hard to get a hold
of and I or a hoie say that that kanji
means to fit together and the kanji is
literally a teapot with the lids sitting
on top of it that's what the kanji
represents and and how that that teapots
are that lid sits perfectly on the pot
and so if you think of how the
of a teapot is and how the the lid sits
on that it sits so nicely and fits so
perfectly and so when you're talking
about Ikey
you're talking about how do we make
energy this abstract weird thing fit
perfectly and so we're talking about
someone else's energy and my energy and
how do we make them fit perfectly so I
think a lot of people who want to study
Aikido and IQ related arts are people
are really interested in the the mental
aspects as much as the physical aspects
so we're gonna talk a little bit in in
sequential videos following videos about
cocoa dough so the concept of cocoa
which is the way i I ate translated is
kind of like the workings of the
conscious and unconscious mind and how
they fit together and the different
kinds of cocoa that you can have and
we'll talk about different kinds of
energies and ideas of energy and
awareness and and mindfulness in Aikido
so I hope you enjoyed these videos and
there will be more to come I'm
Christopher Hine thanks for watching